Mike Pence is running for president one
of the most electric and inspiring
candidates no that's not true that's
actually very much untrue uh Mike Pence
this is a weird 2024 Republican primary
already Mike Pence also spoke at the
Iowa roast and ride and it is actually
stunning how Mike Pence is embroiled in
a battle with Ron DeSantis for who could
possibly be the least charismatic
candidate so far here is pence in a
speech no one understood nor cared about
[Applause]
it is great to be back at the roast and
ride
I rode and I roasted on the ride wow
just absolutely electric delivery as you
can see there
um Pence seemingly out of ideas he sort
of you know how on gun violence it's
like we've tried nothing and we're all
out of ideas is very often what you hear
from some on the right
um Pence so far has really tried nothing
to justify his candidacy and he's just
doing a little bit of the DeSantis stuff
talking about Bud Light and you know
Target I don't think that this is if
DeSantis can't win with this stuff I
don't know that Pence can win with the
exact same stuff he also has to stand up
for American families okay
you know the truth the matter is we
stand here today yeah the radical left
has been assaulting our values and
assaulting our families almost as never
before well talk to me about how that's
going to get me a better paying job or
more job security Mike oh right it won't
it's the same nonsense DeSantis is
peddling
but the great thing I've seen traveling
across this country is that the American
people
American people are on tour
are they just ask Bud Light
Target
and by the way
a message to Major League Baseball
religious bigotry has no place in
America's pastime you can tell he really
means it because he's moving his hands
[Applause]
all right and Pence pointing to someone
into the crowd and mouthing thank you as
you can see this campaign does not
exactly have Victory written all over it
here is Mike Pence interviewed either
right before or right after this thing
he's wearing some kind of biker vest it
might be leather it might be pleather
and
um asked about his big announcement
which is scheduled for tomorrow and if
anybody was worried that Mike Pence's
announcement might not be blessed by God
he has been praying about it he notifies
us ride 50 miles into the uh the State
Fairgrounds if that doesn't say I'm
running for president I don't know what
is are you ready to make it official
well we're looking forward to being back
in Iowa next Wednesday yeah Karen and I
spent a lot of time over the last two
years reflecting and frankly praying
about where we might uh the same God
that told George W bush to go into Iraq
when he prayed is apparently advising
the pences next serve our country after
our years in Congress our years as
governor of Indiana and yours as vice
president and we've come to a decision I
thought there'd be no better place to
announce yeah our decision than right
here in the Hawkeye State
super super exciting as you can see so
listen how it
how is Mike what is Mike Pence doing how
is Mike Pence doing in this race the
latest polling has Mike Pence at an
anemic 3.8 percent I'll be honest I
don't even know how Mike Pence has a
path to getting ahead of Ron DeSantis
never mind catching Donald Trump I don't
understand Mike Pence's argument for
even being a candidate if you didn't
like the Trump Administration Pence was
part of that Administration if you did
like the Trump Administration Trump's
running and you can vote for Trump and
if you didn't like Trump but you want
someone with a viable path to Victory
you've got Ron DeSantis if you want a
woman representing the Republican Party
you've got Nikki Haley if you want a
black guy representing the Republican
Party you've got Tim Scott if you want
a guy who's good at debating
representing the Republican Party you've
got Chris Christie I don't know what
path there is for this guy and it makes
me wonder why is he running at all I
haven't heard him justify it in any way
that makes sense maybe somebody in the
audience has a clue let me know make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the David
Pacman show that's a forward slash folks
don't go in with those backslashes don't
don't you dare I love my Helix Sleep
mattress I've been sleeping on Helix
mattresses for years now which is why I
asked them to be a sponsor you actually
take their famous sleep quiz takes just
a few minutes to answer questions about
your sleep preferences body type sleep
position whether you have back pain and
Helix will match you with a mattress
that's perfect for you which is really
unique and helpful because a lot of
people don't know where to start when
buying a mattress I certainly didn't
their newest collection of mattresses
called Helix Elite come with a built-in
glacial text layer to keep you cool at
night an extra layer of foam for
pressure relief and thousands of extra
micro coils for Best in Class support
and durability all of their mattresses
ship right to your door totally free
they come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
and you get 100 nights to decide if you
like it my audience also gets a whopping
20 off all order plus two free pillows
go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link is
in the description